sécurité sociale le gouvernement
continue de préparer son plan
un conseil interministériel a eu lieu
aujourd'hui à matignon une centaine de
manifestants de la cgt et de la cfdt ont
défilé devant le ministère de la santé
pour montrer leur inquiétude une
inquiétude générale devant le déficit à
résorber 3 milliards de francs pour
cette année seuls cela dit bien que l'on
ne connaisse
aucune des mesures qui seront prises ce
dont on est sûr c'est qu'une vaste
campagne sera lancée pour rendre chaque
français plus conscients des problèmes
de la santé et de leur coût à commencer
bien sûr par les médecins puisque ce
sont eux qui prescrivent d'abord les
soins aux malades
il n'y a pas un responsable unique de la
crise de la sécurité sociale si les
dépenses de santé augmentent de 20% par
an ce qui est un rythme insoutenable
c'est pour de multiples raisons des
journées d'hospitalisation trop cher des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
trop gourmand la publicité l'emballage
représente environ le tiers du prix d'un
médicament des congés maladie trop
fréquent des maladies fléaux comme
l'alcoolisme et le tabagisme qui ne
recule pas tout cela contribue à gonfler
les dépenses
il y a aussi la fameuse surconsommation
de médicaments est derrière elle celui
qui prescrits par ordonnance le médecin
dans le cadre général les accroissements
condamnant sa convenance actuellement il
n'apparaît pas que la pharmacie souhaite
un poste qui soit particulièrement
spectaculaire parmi d'autres au
contraire elles gardent grosso modo
le pourcentage qu'elle a vu depuis des
années dans le cadre des dépenses de
santé donc je crois pas qu'ils aient ce
soir là un poste qui s'accroissent
particules de façon particulièrement
important chapeau 2 sur lequel on
pourrait faire des économies c'est ce
qu'on dit c'est ce qu'on peut penser sur
certains points mais je pense qu'on ne
peut pas le prendre comme ça par le
petit bout c'est à dire il faut
prescrire moins
je pense que c'est lié à une certaine
conception de la médecine sans doute une
certaine conception de la formation de
médecins également peut-être également à
des problèmes d'organisation de la
distribution des soins de l'emmener
d'organisation de la distribution
pharmaceutique qui a la possibilité de
modifier d'infléchir un petit peu la
dépense en masse aux tic par plusieurs
bouts sans penser qu'on va obtenir qu'on
veut en obtenir de résultats très
spectaculaire vous pensez avoir une
grande confiance en vos confrères mais
ne pensez vous pas que certains
exagèrent un peu sur les ordonnances sur
la durée des prescriptions
si vous voulez
certainement de même qu'il y a
vraisemblablement des garagistes qui
changent plus de pièces qui ne faudrait
dans un moteur de même qu'il ya des
avocats qui passent le plus de temps qui
ne conviendrait peut-être certains
d'aussi longs ça ne nous arrive tout au
moins qu'il le dise je veux dire que
effectivement est vraisemblable que
certains praticiens pour des raisons
pour d'autres prescrivent plus qu'il ne
serait peut-être nécessaire sur
l'employé d'autres méthodes
thérapeutiques en marge d'un chiffre à
retenir selon une enquête de la
fédération nationale des coopératives de
consommateurs
en un an les produits pharmaceutiques
non remboursés je précise bien ont
augmenté de 17%